- [Lecturer] This is a super cute puppy.
He has a pink tongue, black fur,
and very friendly personality.
We know that when this puppy grows up,
he will have a healthy
weight of about 70 pounds,
he will love to play fetch,
and enjoy snuggles with his human family.
We know this because these traits
are typical of his breed, Labradors.
But where do these traits come from?
In this video, we're gonna find out.
But first, let's start at the beginning.
What exactly are traits?
Traits are specific
observable characteristics.
They can be physical, like
our puppy's eye color.
They can be behavioral,
such as a dog being
more or less aggressive
towards strangers.
Or they can be health
related, such as a dog's risk
of developing a certain disease.
Traits are passed from
parents to offspring.
This is why our puppy looks
so similar to his parents
who were also Labradors.
But, how does this occur?
Well, traits are passed on
from one generation to the next
through the inheritance of genes.
Genes are pieces of hereditary material
that are passed from parents to offspring.
Genes are found inside
of an organism's cells
as part of structures called chromosomes.
In multicellular organisms,
chromosomes are found
inside the cell nucleus.
Chromosomes are often shown
as X-shaped structures
like this one.
Each chromosome is a structure
that contains one long molecule
of DNA, which stands for
♪ Deoxyribonucleic acid ♪
All right, sing it with me.
Or DNA, for short.
Here's a model showing a small
stretch of a DNA molecule.
You can see that it's made up of lots
of different atoms represented
by these colored balls.
The DNA molecule in a
chromosome is like this,
but much, much longer.
A chromosome's DNA molecule is coiled
up in an organized way.
This diagram shows what
the DNA would look like
if it were stretched out.
This allows us to see
where a chromosome's genes are located.
Genes are specific stretches
of a chromosome's DNA molecule.
Each chromosome's DNA can contain hundreds
or even thousands of genes.
And in multicellular organisms,
each cell contains multiple chromosomes.
It's the collection of
genes and chromosomes
that contain the information
about all of an organism's
inherited traits.
Like our puppy here, his
chromosomes contain thousands
of genes to help him determine
his coat color, eye color,
and all the other traits he
inherited from his parents.
So our puppy must have one or more genes
that caused him to have black fur.
If he had been born
with different versions
of the fur colored genes,
he may have had yellow
or brown fur.
Heck, maybe one day
someone will figure out
how to change a puppy's DNA
so that he has pink fur.
And who knows?
Maybe you'll be the
geneticist to make it happen.
That's it for today.
Thanks for watching.
And I hope to be seeing some
pink puppies one day soon.